قتلى وجرحى في زلزال هز الاكوادور وبيرو
زياره مفاجئه لبوتين الى ماريوبل
الاوكرانيه خوفا من انتقال العدوى بنوك
امريكيات تناشد السلطات هذه الاخبار
وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه العربيه فاهلا
بكم
[موسيقى]
زلزال جديد يهز العالم لكن هذه المره
بعيدا عن منطقتنا حيث قتل نحو 14 شخصا على
الاقل واصيب اخرون جراء زلزال ضرب جنوب
الاكوادور وشعر به سكان بيرو استنادا الى
حصيله رسميه المعهد الامريكي لرصد الزلازل
افاد بان الزلزال بلغت قوته 6.8 درجه حين
دعا رئيس الاكوادور مواطنه الى الهدوء
بعدما اثار الزلزال حاله من الظهر بين
السكان الذين نزلوا الى الشوارع اثرا
انهيار منازل في مدن عده بينها مدينه
كونكا الاكثر تضررا
في زياره مفاجئه هي الاولى من نوعها
ظهر رئيس روسي بلاير بوتين في مدينه
ماريوبل الاوكرانيه التي سيطرت عليها
القوات الروسيه واعلنت روسيا ضمها
لاراضيها بوتين الذي سافر الى ماريوبل
بطائره مروحيه التقى هناك بالقياده العليا
لعمليته العسكريه في اوكرانيا فيما جاءت
الزياره بعد يومين من اصدار المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه مذكره تطويف بحقه بتهم
تتعلق بجرائم الحرب الامر الذي قلل من
شانه الكرملين
مع تصاعدي شبح انهيار القطاع المصرفي في
امريكا طلب ائتلاف يضم بنوكا امريكيا
متوسطه الحجم الهيئه المنظمه الفيدراليه
للمصارف بضمان جميع ودائع عملائهم لمده
عامين وحتى لتلك المبالغ التي تفوق الحد
البالغ 250 الف دولار وتفاديا من انتقال
العدوى عدوى افلاس بنك سيليكومبالي قال
ائتلاف البنوك الامريكيه في رساله بعث بها
الى السلطات ان ذلك الاجراء من شانه ان
يوقف الهروب ومحاولات الهروب الخاصه
بالودائع من مصارف اصغر حجما ويؤدي الى
استقرار القطاع المصرفي ويقلل بشكل كبير
من احتمالات انهيار مزيد من البنوك
مع اقتراب حلول الشهر الفضيل اجرت وكاله
مجمع الملك عبد العزيز لكسوه الكعبه
المشرفه صيانه الكسوه للحفاظ على رونقها
وظهورها في ابها حاله وحله لها استعدادا
لشهر رمضان المبارك اعمال الصيانه تتلخص
في تركيب قماش بارتفاع ثلاثه امتار من
جميع الجوانب للكعبه المشرفه وكذلك شد
ووزن ثوب الكعبه وتثبيته من الاطراف
بالاضافه الى اعمال تنظيف الكسوه من جميع
الاتجاهات كما سيجرى تغيير القطع المطرزه
المحيطه بكل من الحجر الاسود والركن
اليماني
بعد ايام قليله من تجاوزها كيليجينز
باعتبارها الانثى الاكثر متابعه على تطبيق
انستجرام حققت النجمه الامريكيه سينا جونز
نجاحا جديدا بوصول عدد المتابعيها في
التطبيق الى اربعه مليون لتصبح اول امراه
تصل الى هذا الرقم وبهذا الانجاز اصبحت
جوميز ثالث اكبر شخصيه متابعه على
انستجرام بعد كريستيانو رونالدو وميسي
فيما ياتي تفوقها على جنس بعدما سخرت
الاخيره بشكل غير مباشر من جوميز ما ادى
الى توجيه ملايين المتابعين الى حسابها